Right, then. I've got a bath running
so I'm gonna make this quick.
This is everything
you need to know
about season one of The Witcher.
Welcome to the Continent,
a land of prophecies, monsters,
mages, elves, and witchers.
A witcher is basically
a monster hunter.
There are few left in this world.
This one is called…
Geralt of Rivia.
So, one day, Geralt comes across
these two, Stregobor and Renfri,
who want to kill each other,
but believe Geralt, the monster hunter,
can do the deed for them.
-They think it's…
-Destiny.
And Geralt's like, "Nobody tells me
what to do, not even destiny."
But then he does get involved
to protect the innocent
and kills Renfri,
who in her last breath mutters…
The girl in the woods
is your destiny.
He's like,
"There's that word again."
And then these ungrateful clowns
cast him out of town.
A bard called Jaskier joins Geralt
on his quest, and is like…
You have got an image problem.
I could change
the public's tune about you.
Geralt gets his ass kicked
by a goat man
and they are captured by elves.
King of the elves,
Filavandrel, is like…
My elders worked with humans.
They were slaughtered.
He goes to cut Geralt's throat,
who's like, "Whatever, mate. Just…"
Don't call me human.
So the elves let them go,
after which this song,
that never lets you sleep,
was born.
You know the words.
Toss a coin to your witcher…
Jaskier's like, "I did you a favor,
so in return,
you can bodyguard me in Cintra,
the most powerful land
on the Continent."
Queen Calanthe
is deciding on a suitor
to marry her daughter,
Princess Pavetta.
At this point, the kingdom
of Nilfgaard is known to be
the less powerful shithole city
further south.
More on them jokers later.
No!
Suddenly, a cursed porcupine man
called Duny is all like,
"I have the right
to your daughter's hand in marriage."
By the Law of Surprise.
For anyone pretending they know
what that means…
Slay this beast!
…if you save someone from a certain death
and don't want money,
you can claim payment
with the Law of Surprise.
Destiny then determines
that payment,
which is something the other person
already possesses
but doesn't know about.
Make sense?
-Well…
-Good.
Of course, Geralt saves Duny
from certain death,
these guys get married,
and the curse is lifted.
As payment for saving his life,
Geralt thinks, "I'll give this a whirl,"
-and claims…
-The Law of Surprise.
It turns out Pavetta is pregnant,
and Geralt's ecstatic
when he realizes
-that the baby is for him to claim.
-Fuck.
This wizard man's like,
"Destiny has spoken."
"If you leave without claiming
this child, we're all fucked."
-And Geralt's like…
-Bullshit.
"Nobody tells me what to do."
But after some years
of not being able to sleep,
Geralt finds a djinn
to fix his problem.
Not that kind of gin.
It's more like a genie… in a bottle.
This one attacks Jaskier,
and Geralt finds help
from this saucy mage.
Yennefer of Vengerberg.
Who is Yennefer of Vengerberg?
Let's go back and find out.
Born with a twisted spine,
Yennefer was bought
by a sorceress named Tissaia
and taken to Aretuza,
a school of magic,
where they learn how to use
this thing called Chaos,
which is basically a magical force
that mages harness
to move stuff and…
Well, you get the gist.
Yennefer's BF or FB, Istredd,
is spying on her,
-and tells the Brotherhood…
-She's part elf.
Everyone hates elves,
so they vote to send Yennefer
to the shitty city Nilfgaard.
Instead of Fringilla.
But Yennefer's like, "Fuck that.
Make me powerful… and pretty."
This guy's like, "You won't
be able to have children."
And she's thinking, "That sounds fixable."
He's thinking, "It's not."
And boom,
sexy Yennefer swoops in
and wins over a king
far away from Nilfgaard.
Someone has to go there.
Fringilla, you up for it?
Never mind.
Since then, Yennefer has been
roaming the land
to find a cure for her womb,
so when Geralt says…
He was attacked by a djinn.
She's like, "Bingo! Baby."
But it gets out of control and
Geralt makes a wish to save her.
The djinn's like,
"I'm free! I'm finally free!"
Yennefer's pissed off, but is like,
"Let's just check to see if it worked."
She wakes up,
and commitment-phobe Geralt
has ghosted her, that bastard.
-Don't judge me.
-Okay, fair enough.
Sometime later,
they coincidentally
enter the same race
to hunt down a dragon.
-Geralt's like…
-What are you doing here, Yen?
And she's like, "Duh!
Dragon hearts cure wombs."
We find out that Nilfgaard has
returned, burning through the south.
With Fringilla as their mage.
You remember Fringilla,
Yennefer's mate from school?
Well this is her new mate, Cahir,
Nilfgaard's commanding officer.
He's cool.
Meanwhile, Geralt lets this slip…
I'd rather use my Child Surprise
as bruxa bait!
You have a Child Surprise?
Busted.
But what the hell is a bruxa?
Well, it's basically a… Wait.
It's definitely too soon to say that.
But if you watch season two,
you can find out for yourself.
Back to these lovebirds.
Knowing Geralt's abandoned a child
when Yennefer is desperate for one
is a bitter pill to swallow.
-Fuck.
-Well recovered, Geralt.
After much drama, action,
and some sweaty sex for good measure,
Yennefer realizes that
Geralt made a wish with the djinn.
That's why we can't escape each other.
She's like, "It's not love, it's magic."
Yennefer dumps Geralt,
-and Geralt tells Jaskier to do one.
-Right, then.
Geralt sees the now-enormous
army of Nilfgaard, and thinks…
"Maybe I should go to Cintra
and check on that kid,"
who is now Princess Cirilla,
or Ciri, of Cintra.
She's been raised
by her grandparents
after her actual parents were lost at sea.
-Geralt gets to Cintra and is like…
-I'm here to protect the girl.
But then Calanthe is like…
You and destiny
can both fuck right off.
And locks him in the dungeon.
Nilfgaard attack,
kill the king,
and take over the city.
Meanwhile the Brotherhood of Mages hear
of Nilfgaard attacking Cintra.
-What?
-And jump at the chance to help.
Who cares?
Okay, so only a small group of mages
team up to stop Nilfgaard at Sodden Hill.
Hold Sodden, save the Continent.
Back in Cintra, Calanthe,
on her deathbed, is like,
-"Maybe Geralt can help."
-Geralt!
Of course, he's fucked off
to release his frustrations.
In her last breath, she tells Ciri…
Find Geralt of Rivia.
He is your destiny.
And Ciri's like, "Geralt of what?"
She leaves with this hero,
is captured by Cahir,
but, luckily, discovers she has
these mega screaming powers…
which you could argue
are groundbreaking.
Ciri escapes into the woods
and Cahir is left thinking,
"How the hell am I gonna
explain this to my boss?"
After some days on the run,
-Ciri meets this elf.
-I'm Dara.
They escape Nilfgaard and Cahir
again at a refugee camp,
arrive at an enchanted forest,
Ciri has a trippy dream,
and they bump into this weirdo.
To which Dara's like, "Screw you,
Bad Luck Princess. I'm off."
Ciri goes at it alone
and is once again attacked,
but after reciting
some badass poetry…
The Time of Madness
and the Time of Contempt.
…we cut to black.
Geralt arrives at the refugee camp
looking for Ciri,
gets bitten by
this lanky motherfucker,
and wakes up tripping his balls off.
Turns out this guy saved him
and they're off to get help.
Ciri wakes up and realizes
she's exploded or something,
killing all these assholes.
She goes with this woman,
who lives near the Battle of Sodden.
Where Nilfgaard are like, "Nobody calls me
a joker. Who's laughing now?"
And Yennefer's like, "Me," and burns
the shit out of them, saving the day.
Fire magic is illegal, by the way.
Ciri has a weird dream of Geralt
and Tissaia looking for Yennefer,
wakes up, and goes
for a stroll in the woods.
In that moment, Geralt arrives
at the same house Ciri was just at,
goes into the woods,
and is finally met with Ciri.
Destiny prevails.
-Ciri's like…
-Who is Yennefer?
And Geralt's like, "What the fuck?"
Right, that's your lot.
You should be all prepped now
for season two.
You are welcome.